Five adult specimens of SCP-939 were selected
for testing with The Clockworks.
“Rough” produced an output of a pile of
bone splinters, broken teeth, and pieces of
translucent red tissue.
This tissue continued to move and twitch on
an occasional basis for several hours before
stopping.
The specimen run through the machine on “Coarse,”
produced several neat, organized piles of
tissue, including its muscles, ground-up bones,
teeth, skin, esophagus, and fifteen kilograms
of rotten human flesh with a D-Class ID tag
on top.
When the next specimen was input on “1:1,”
the output was [REDACTED]
The next specimen was placed on the setting
“Fine,” and it produced the exact same
specimen of adult SCP-939.
The only notable difference was that it had
stopped breathing.
On the setting “Very Fine,” the experiment
produced a pile of smoldering white ash.